Frank Capra said there are no rules and
filmmaking only sins and the cardinal
sin is dullness the five nominees for
Best Director were anything but dull
we're fortunate to live in a time when
powerful and lasting films are made by
filmmakers such as these here are the
nominees for achievement in directing
Alejandro G in yachty to Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance Richard
Linklater boyhood Bennett Miller
Foxcatcher Wes Anderson the grand
Budapest hotel morten tyldum the
imitation game alright and the Academy
Award for achievement in directing goes
to Alejandro G
good luck charm work because in the DA
Awards I was wearing a Raymond Carver
shirt Billy Wilder tie and I won but
today tonight I am wearing the real
Michael Keaton tighty whities thank you
they are tight smell likes balls but it
work I'm here thank you Michael
uh honestly I mean this is crazy in a
way talking about that little prick
called ego ego loves competition right
because for someone to win someone has
to lose but the paradox is that you know
true art truths individual expression as
all the work of these incredible fellow
filmmakers can't be compared can be
labeled can't be the feat because they
exist and our work only will be judged
as always by time so I am you know is
very thankful grateful humbly honored by
the Academy which I think for this
incredible recognition which I have it
here because the work of all the actors
all the producers chavalla whiskey which
I didn't mention TiVo I love you you are
the genius you are the artists of our
generation
Martina Mandy's Antonio Sanchez so many
people that work in this film and
obviously again you know I forgot
worldview I forgot so many people this
is like a slow-motion kind of moment in
my life so forget if I forgot everybody
I love you an un saludo a todos mis
compatriot as Mohicans thank
very much